hey everyone welcome into Market takes
you know what I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me and I appreciate that I am Dion
Robert Bowen reporter for the Wall
Street Journal listen it is a short week
but we are still getting lots of data
out this week I'm going to tell you the
three most important things you need to
look out for this week and they are
three reports that are all coming out on
Thursday we'll be right here doing
Market takes Thursday at noon we usually
do it at 10 A.M so make sure you adjust
your uh your sleep cycle and all that so
you catch us here on Market takes
Thursday at noon but we're going to be
talking through today the existing home
sales report that comes out on Thursday
the leading economic indicators report
that comes out on Thursday and the
initial jobless claims report that also
comes out on Thursday Thursday is going
to be a big day I'm going to tell you
why so first things first let's talk
about that existing home sales report
that is the main report on the housing
market because most homes that are sold
in the United States are existing homes
and already built homes not new homes
one that you buy that was built in the
50s 60s 70s 80s etc etc that's the big
one and that shows us what's happening
with about 80 percent of the housing
market but what we have seen recently is
some data on those new home sales that
suggests that maybe that's part of the
market is heating up and the existing
home sales Market could be heating up as
well so far this week we have already
gotten the nahb housing market index as
well as the home uh new home starts or
housing starts that data came out on
Monday and uh just this morning on
Tuesday we have seen a big pickup first
things first I want to throw up here on
your screen the nahb housing market
index now this data shows a very clear
Trend and this is what we're seeing
across the new homes part of the housing
market very clearly home sales declining
declining declining and that's really
Market sentiment that's how folks feel
about the housing market when we talk
about the existing home sales report or
sorry when we talk about the housing
market report that's a survey of about
900 home builders a reading above 50
indicates a favorable outlook on home
sales below 50 indicates a negative
outlook and as you see up there on your
screen we had fallen well below 50.
hitting almost that 30 level at the end
of last year and then starting this year
you see month over month every month
picking up and Rising higher and so just
last month we got or I'm sorry yeah just
last month we got a reading of 55 on
that on that Outlook and so that just
illustrating very clearly that
confidence optimism the outlook on the
housing market is really picking up
those home builders are going out
building more homes putting more
inventory out there that should provide
more Supply and as we know there's a lot
of demand and Supply is rising that
could do something to bring down houses
or to bring down prices excuse me in the
overall housing market but again we have
not really seen that same pickup and we
need to see a decline in the number of
existing homes sold to bring down those
prices so a very clear Trend when we see
what's going on with uh with the home
builder index with new home sales new
home sales actually were the highest
since May of 22 two we also saw the nihp
housing index that was the highest since
July of 2022 and the new home sales I'm
sorry housing starts was the highest
since May of 2022 and we saw those new
home sales Rising a big way to the
highest since May of 2022 as well so
housing starts which is the
forward-looking indicator how many homes
were actually built housing construction
or how many new residential permits
started on being built that was the
highest since May of 2022. the nahb
housing market index showing home
builder confidence sentiment all that
highest since July of 2022 and the new
home sales was the Hyacinth May of 2022
with 683 000 units sold this really just
showing us that the housing market is
booming and coming back in a big way on
the new home side but as I said earlier
existing home sales are what really
matter and we will get that report on
Thursday and we're going to find out if
the existing home sales trend has
continued along with the new home sales
Trend so let's throw a pure chart on
your screen of the existing home sales
and what we've seen from that report as
you see there new home sales have been
declining in that same way over the past
year into the end of the year and then
in January we got a big pickup in the
number of new and the number of existing
home sales sold excuse me and that show
and that has actually been declining so
if we see that Trend continue that could
put downward pressure on prices and that
could be a good thing for the housing
market now that chart up there on your
screen just illustrating that we have
seen you know a turn down in existing
home sales but still above the level and
the trend that we saw coming into the
end of last year why does that matter
for the everyday average person well if
we if home sales prices are coming down
right that means that rents can come
down because those landlords that are
buying those houses and renting them out
to people aren't going to be paying as
much they're not going to need to make
as much in rent to justify that purchase
that's going to allow them to give some
flexibility to their tenants going with
the overall economy but if those prices
keep Rising keep getting higher as we've
seen with the new home sales Market that
can put upward pressure on inflation
push inflation back up that gets to the
FED that gets to asset prices all of
those things so that would be an overall
negative for the market so you're going
to want to watch that existing home
sales report that we get out on Thursday
we're expecting to see another decline
in may just like we saw in previous
months in April and in March before that
but if we don't get that and we get an
unexpected pickup that could be bad news
for the market so you'll want to watch
out for that next thing I want to talk
about is the leading index or the
leading economic indicators index I want
to put a chart up here on your screen to
show you what we're seeing from that
report as well now this report much less
bullish there's really not a lot to it
as you see there when the when the index
starts falling below when the index of
leading economic indicators Falls below
zero we tend to have recessions you see
that when it holds below that
consistently recessions tend to follow
it and we saw it in 2008 we saw it in
2020 and it looks like right now we're
seeing that same Trend and actually a
more clear and long-term Trend in that a
leading economic indicators report so
that charges illustrate just the clear
Trend that we are in right now with
those numbers May expected to show
another decline actually a bigger
decline than what we saw in April
in April the leading economic indicators
report declined for the 13th straight
month so we've seen more than a year of
to continued decline on that report and
actually it is a steeper rate of decline
for the previous six months than the six
months before that so really just
showing right now things are not good
the Lei is the conference board index it
usually is a good predictor of GDP GDP
is how we measure recession so when it
goes down generally we tend to be in
recessionary territory includes things
like the S P 500 the treasury yield
curve credit indexes but also a lot of
things like manufacturing data uh
business surveys like the ism and
purchasing managers indexes so we know
the s p is really picked up we know that
stocks have been booming lately that
could push that index back into positive
territory definitely will be something
you want to look out for uh the eight
the Atlanta feds GDP now report showing
expectations for the effect or for the
GDP to come in positive almost right at
two percent the Federal Reserve is
expecting GDP to recover this year and
stay out of that negative territory so
we shall see this will be a good report
that you'll want to watch on Thursday
about what happens last thing we want to
talk about is those initial jobless
claims number let's put this chart up
here on your screen of initial jobless
claims and look at that you see there
we're seeing a clear trend of picking up
but most importantly as you see on the
far right of your screen those lace
those last two numbers have been the
highest we've seen since January 2022 so
well above the trend and we have seen we
don't know if those are outliers are
those something like what we saw a few
weeks ago or a couple months ago with
Massachusetts having some fraud in its
claims are those though the start of a
trend and if they are could we be seeing
big pickups in in unemployment and
layoffs and could that be a sign that
the job market is starting to weaken the
labor market is starting the weekend so
keep your eyes on on this report the U.S
initial jobless claims that's how many
people are applying for unemployment
insurance and things like that because
they've been laid off this chart
illustrating that we have seen a very
clear pickup over the last two weeks in
that data and we will send will look and
continue to see if that Trend continues
so we're going to break all that down
here on Thursday at noon on Market takes
I hope you'll be with us I hope you'll
be with me as as you are today thank you
so much I'm Dion rabone reporter with
the Wall Street Journal and we will see
you right back here Thursday at noon on
Market takes see you next time